please matpat do a theory on shorts Wars
matpat needs to take a look at the
YouTube shorts ARG there is now aarg
this might be part of a well-known
YouTube
okay okay I get it we're doing the
shorts War wait they just ended damn it
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film film film
Theory Theory the show that just wants
you to Sub Sub sub
subscribe strange the overwhelming
glitchiness seems to indicate that we're
covering an ARG today and not just any
air G this one is found right here on
the shores of youtube.com specifically
we're talking about the shorts Wars and
ARG star in a variety of different
short-centric channels including bundon
Dano Cal drawings Joe Kane Royal pair
failure and the biggest of them all at
least according to subscribership Johnny
Razer now if you're not familiar with
the last one it's likely that you're
familiar with the Fallout of his work
remember a few months ago when everyone
suddenly became very invested in The
Waffle House finding itself a new host
well that was the brainchild of Mr bad
ideas Johnny Razer himself and now he
and that crew of other creators are at
it again or not really them rather it's
an army of clones replacing them
regardless they are up to some new
tricks and it's up to us to figure out
what's going on obviously like after the
fact like if matpat makes the video
you'll be able to watch that and you you
get the gym yes but like being there
every day where it's like the new videos
going up getting all of that in real
time is so cool and like really helps
like the theorizing a lot uh like I was
saying it's up to us to come around a
bit later in the process to recap what
happened put the pieces together and
then solve what's going on thanks guys
for recognizing that daily lore drops
are really hard for us to cover in real
time now if all of this is new to you
then I recommend you go to check out
their channels links for all of them are
down there in the description below
because what this group has created over
the past month is one of the most fun
uses of YouTube that I've seen happen in
a long long time this thing spans over a
hundred shorts live streams multiple
hidden unlisted videos oh and let's not
forget the website that's no longer
available so go hunt around see what
you're able to put together and make
sure you subscribe to them since you're
probably going to want to be there when
they inevitably do a season two of this
thing so let's do what they openly
acknowledge that we do best and give you
the just what happened what you may have
missed along the way and then predict
what season two has got in store grab
your QR codes and fishing poles loyal
theorists as today we're untangling The
Mystery of the shorts War ARG let's just
start back at the beginning how this
whole thing kicked off the ball got
rolling when Johnny Razer posted a short
to his channel that at first didn't seem
all that out of the ordinary you got
Johnny telling a story in front of a
green screen with some Minecraft Parkour
playing around in the background classic
short stuff but then the video glitches
out with a QR code briefly flashing on
screen before returning to normal
scanning the QR code redirects you to an
unlisted video called message.mp4
featuring a masked man with a voice
filter this ominous bad guy goes by a
lot of different names across the fan
Community but we're going to be calling
him the boss for this video and right
off the bat the boss makes his opinions
about YouTube shorts and specifically
their creators quite clear before too
long
during this villain monologue we see
eight channels flash up across the
screen Johnny Razer MOG swamp Royal pair
Joe Kane Daniel Kell drawings can Splash
bun done and failure the boss ends up
giving these creators an ultimatum they
need to stop making shorts within the
next week or they will be quote unquote
replaced that right there that is
ominous since the ARG started on July
16th that meant that they only had until
July 23rd one week later to stop and as
it turns out two of the creators MOG
swamp and can Splash actually took the
message to heart I guys are all asking
me why I stopped making shorts I I
really can't talk about it but it has to
do with basically a message I received
kind of want to say like a threat I will
that was totally a threat but since
those two complied with the boss's
orders they are not part of the story
from that point forward at least for
this particular season this then leaves
our main six creators and let's just say
by the end of that first week they were
probably wishing they'd heeded the
warnings begun the shorts Wars have over
the next week some Oddities start
plaguing the remaining six creators as
their videos roll out what kind of
oddities we talking about well you'd be
watching a failure video when all of a
sudden you see Johnny Razer Gangnam
styling throughout the frame in fact
across all the channels we start to see
these sorts of crossover glitches what's
more if you look at the actual content
of these videos a common theme starts to
develop it's cloning humans possible I
bet you can't clone me Kobe I bet you I
can I bet you he can as a sell source
for cloning must be from living tissue
like Skin So saliva wouldn't work Tick
Tock has a massive problem and it has to
do with clones all of a sudden these
creators can't stop talking about clones
almost like they're worried about being
replaced but believe it or not that
wasn't even the strangest thing to start
happening in the videos a bunch of the
shorts started hiding this random string
of 11 characters in their videos which
immediately got my theorist sense as a
tingling normally this would be where we
whip out our Caesar ciphers or Dakota
rings but here there's no need thanks to
working on YouTube longer than most of
the audience watching it's been alive I
instantly recognize this as a YouTube
video ID so I slapped it into a URL and
was taken to this unlisted video called
clonevpn.mp4 clone there's that word
again anyway at first this doesn't seem
so different from the millions of other
ads for vpns that you see across YouTube
already we all love the internet but
with all the problems of the world today
there's no better time to invest in a
VPN so choose us clonevpn is the VPN of
all time you get it we get it we've all
seen a billion VPN ad reads at this
point we also get a list of the Clone
VPN Partners which features a lot of the
people that were expressly called out by
the boss but then we get to this feature
right here that truly sets clonevpn
apart and let me tell you we're not
talking about unlocking International
streaming rights that aren't available
in your country and with our disappear
reappear
[Music]
from your content clones disappearing
and reappearing slight but unnoticeable
changes yeah the narrative is clearly
forming here the boss is gonna somehow
clone and replace these YouTube shorts
creators through clonevpn now the only
question is how well I'm gonna tell you
the how in a minute but before that I
can tell you the how they could have
avoided this threat entirely if only the
shorts creators had used the sponsor for
today's video incognate Yeah step aside
their clone VPN we've got a real sponsor
in the house tell me if this one sounds
familiar the other week I was out at the
grocery store stocking up on a
gallon-sized jug of Diet Coke and I
signed up for their loyalty card to get
a discount I thought that I could trust
the store and yet lo and behold I almost
immediately started getting all these
spammy emails and scam phone calls
another time I was searching up
information about Mattel for our Barbie
video that we just released and now all
the ads that I see everywhere are Amazon
links to Hot Wheels and Ken dolls this
happens because in the United States
it's totally legal for companies to
track collect and sell your personal
data without you knowing anything about
it and it's not just your email and
shopping habits that these corporations
are getting a hold of it is a lot of
your private information as well stuff
that you do not want to get out into the
public we're talking your full name your
home address your phone number your
relatives alias's education employment
history heck even your social security
number there is no world where they need
to know any of that stuff the good news
here is that you have the right to
request that these data Brokers delete
your information that way you can sleep
safe and sound at night knowing that
you're not going to get a random phone
call at midnight trying to sell you the
latest Barbie Malibu dream mansion the
downside to everything though might take
you actual real years to get all your
info scrubbed clean and Cognito can help
you with that well services like vpns
are defensive trying to keep your info
out of the hands of these corporations
and cogni actually goes on the offense
they're going to be your representative
and track down the brokers who are
actively selling your personal
information out there and then they
demand that they leave you alone delete
your stuff from the system your personal
information is being bought and sold and
you are getting nothing out of it except
a nuisance time to change that and
incogni is the key to Hell let me tell
you after signing up for their service
to test it out for myself I saw the
difference overnight gone where all the
obnoxious spam emails that I was getting
and as far as phone calls go I don't get
any spam or otherwise which is exactly
the way it should be if you want to
protect your data today go to
incogni.com film Theory and use the code
film Theory to get 60 off an annual
incognate plan again that's incogni.com
f-i-l-m-t-h-e-o-r-y and then use the
code film Theory or you know he could
just skip all that Hassle and just go
down to the Top Line of description
thanks again to incogni for sponsoring
this video and keeping my personal
information out of the boss's hands and
now let's hop back to the shorts Wars
see when you're dealing with a malicious
AI or evil VPN program in order for it
to harm you or your computer you need to
let it in so to speak viruses operate on
vampire rules they have to be invited in
by running a program or clicking a bad
link or something well that's exactly
what all these shorts creators did on
July 20th Royal pair uploaded short with
another hidden video ID here we see the
shorts creators finding an email in
their inbox from clonevpn reaching out
for a sponsorship deal they're offered a
crisp twenty thousand dollars for an ad
read and wanted to secure the bag they
each click a not so suspicious link
nothing can possibly go wrong from that
right somehow this allows the boss to
access their computers and use their
online identities as a base to clone
them how can we be sure about this well
everyone accepts the Clone VPN deal
except for one of them Joe Kane huh
sponsorship clonevpn no I don't think so
the only thing I'm ready to promote is
genshin
yep the internet's favorite short Speed
Run and Swede turns down the deal and as
you can tell by the text that flashes
across the screen as he closes the email
the boss ain't too happy about it but
the rest of his master plan is
proceeding on schedule you see on July
22nd the day before the boss's ultimatum
comes due I found QR codes hidden in
Johnny Razer and Dano's channels that
take us to an unlisted video that shows
us exactly how the Clone sausage gets
made we find ourselves in some sort of
scientific facility and one by one
information about each YouTuber is
uploaded into some strange machine the
computer Powers up and using all the
data a literal clone of the creators is
generated in the physical world it's
here that we see that the boss is true
to his word both the good and the bad
both MOG swamp and can Splash aren't
clone because they listen to the boss
and stopped making shorts while the
others are cloned though some turn out
better than others Johnny Razer failure
and bundun's clones are made without an
issue but during the cloning process for
Royal pair there's an error R34 that
appears on the screen of the machine and
it's at this point that the people on
team theorists that aren't familiar with
the rules of the internet realize that
they probably shouldn't be Googling
Royal pair R34 masterful troll there
guys anyway that error causes the clone
machine to create a malformed clone of
Royal pair's normal Tropius design the
final clone to be made in the machine is
Dano's Channel's character riggy
interestingly since the riggy character
was the one who clicked the sponsorship
link on behalf of Dano the Creator he's
the one who got himself cloned however
due to his giant bunny ears and long
monkey tail the machine hilariously
can't figure out what species he's meant
to be and the Machine partially blows up
but not before spitting out a strange
looking clone of riggy just without the
tail as the 23rd rolls around in the
boss's deadline passes the Clones are
deployed to the various channels and we
see their violent Takeover in some
comically over the top yet still YouTube
monetization friendly violence Johnny
razer's clone shoots his original seven
times in the chest undone is kidnapped
under the table mid-video while riggy
thaler and Royal pairs clones are taken
away to some unknown fate but for all
the creators the results are the same
each of the new clone creators uploads
an ad for clonevpn all of which are
basically carbon copies of the same
thing it's almost like they're all
clones of each other you're in danger on
average a single person will visit 130
web pages per day but what's scary is
that an estimated 10 of all websites are
malicious or out to get you so basically
this gives us a glimpse of what happens
when the boss wins the Clones are just
shoveling out content now they're
recycling scripts they're reusing ideas
They're copying one another in an
endless loop of video sludge what's even
worse though is that a new date's being
seen in the background of some of the
newly uploaded shorts pointing to July
30th this is the day where all the
original creators will be killed and the
Clone Invasion will be complete so is
that it is all hope lost for these
shorts creators as these half-rate
clones come in and just take over the
content thankfully no the OG creators
are fighting back from the inside all
through the videos they leave notes
saying that they're still alive with
Johnny Razer somehow surviving being
shot seven times now he himself is
hatching a plan behind the scenes to get
into the facility and save the day using
a special flash drive that he somehow
magically obtained how don't ask at
least not yet but the clock is ticking
and they don't have much time before
July 30th comes to pass and many of the
creators are killed for good namely both
Royal pear and riggy are in the most
immediate danger as both are currently
being held in the Clone VPN facility but
they're not going to take it lying down
on July 29th Dano uploaded a short where
clone riggy finally goes off the deep
end a QR code is hidden at the end of
this one leading us to a then unlisted
video titled where did riggy go.mp4 here
we see both riggy and pair being
interrogated by their clones but riggy
is able to escape free pair and book it
towards an exit interestingly the end
card of this one actually takes us to
another video with audio of a
conversation between clone riggy and the
boss and let's just say that the boss
man is not happy with royal pair and
riggy's escape and we learned that the
two found the facility's control room
while exiting the building I can see the
exit it's right up ahead hold on is that
a control room judging by the sign on
the door I'd say yeah if we don't shut
down the Clones we'll just get sent
right back here realizing that their PNG
tubers and therefore two-dimensional
riggy and pair slip through the door and
they see that the boss's plan is way
bigger than they ever realized all of
them have codes it seems like whoever
uses the code sends more energy to the
cloning machine and it looks like it's
getting ready to clone every shorts
YouTuber yep the boss's big plan is to
use his VPN sponsorship to clone every
shorts tuber and replace them with just
garbage content and given how widespread
VPN sponsorships are guessing he's gonna
be able to get every single YouTuber on
the platform in less than a month but
thankfully there's a way to stop his
plan once and for all if they pull all
the codes together and use the energy to
overload the machine they can use that
power to create a virus that'll knock
out clonevpn forever what then is the
code well here's where things get really
cool remember when all the Clones did
those sponsorship videos back when they
first took over well each video ends
with a promo code that features two to
three characters their name and then a
number one to five now I saw this and
knew it had to mean something by
removing the Creator names and then
ordering what's left buy those numbers
at the end you get this now surprisingly
that isn't a YouTube video ID even
though it's the same length and format
so I assume that it was some sort of a
code or a cipher but that also didn't
work we just didn't have all the
information at the time this is what
that code is 4 4. it was yet another
masterful Troll And I gotta admit this
time this time they definitely got me
but there's a problem they need someone
on the outside to enter the code
thankfully they remember that Joe Kane
refused the deal and hasn't been
captured
okay if I have to do it we need to hide
it from him scan in the QR code that
pops up on screen sends us to another
secret video where Joe puts the code
into the clonevpn website which lets a
riggy and pair create the virus a virus
that just so happens to teleport into
the possession of Johnny razor yep
that's where he got the drive from a
fact that the boss realizes in real time
exactly yes and there was someone on the
end to receive it
of course
[Applause]
though we don't actually see it happen
Razer uploads the virus which then
allows each of the creators to have a
1v1 battle against their clones to
regain control and end this Saga once
and for all with the creators Victorious
we're treated to a post-credits scene
where the boss and clone riggy vow to
come back and then it's here that we get
our big twist ending they've all
regained control
useless clones what are we gonna do now
we are going to do something far greater
than our original plans because now I'm
angry and the best part is they stubborn
nose in control the flannel Johnny razor
was the boss the entire time no that's
not possible but but no really that's
that's literally not possible right if
Johnny was the one who uploaded the
virus and saved the day that means that
he played an integral part in his own
plan failing doesn't really make a whole
lot of sense I mean sure maybe you could
argue that riggy did the smart thing and
went to the server room by himself with
this post ARG q a stream seems to argue
otherwise before the website went down
uh what was Joe Kane originally supposed
to do originally he was gonna send me
the flash drive but then we changed it
to like take down the website and have
riggy send the flash drive instead even
if we ignore these non-canon live
streams and the logic of the show Johnny
can't be the big boss remember earlier
when the boss said this
why does it always come back to razor it
doesn't make sense why he'd both pretend
to hate Razer and then openly admit that
he's a razor in the very next scene so
now this man can't be the real Johnny
razor so is it a clone then well
Johnny's clone is
take that you stupid clone son of a oh
hey didn't see you there yeah he's not
having the best time so if the boss is
neither the real or clone version of
Johnny razor then who is he third clone
PewDiePie me this is where I have to
wave the white flag at least for now I
don't think there's quite enough
information out there to solve that
mystery just yet and I suspect that the
boss's identity will be revealed when
Short's War has its season 2 which I for
one am totally stoked for I gotta say
this has gotta be one of the coolest
args that I've seen happen across the
YouTube and what's more I believe the
story that these creators told has a lot
more meaning than just a bunch of clones
taken over see while watching this I
kept coming back to the question what's
the point and and I don't mean that in a
harsh like why did they make this sort
of way no I wanted to know what theme
they were trying to communicate through
all this and I believe that we find that
in the entire concept of this thing
clones the story of this first season of
the shorts war is a commentary uncloged
content across the internet I'm sure
you've seen these sorts of things around
before either YouTube channels or tick
tocks or whatever I'll just rip content
from other websites and re-upload them
trying to make a quick Buck off of
someone else's work it's a problem that
we here at theists have to deal with all
the time and it's something that Johnny
Razer himself even talked about before
the shorts War ARG began I have been
cloned not in a lab but on Tick Tock
this I believe is what sparked the whole
idea of the ARG see the Clones that we
see in the series could never truly
replace the creators because they aren't
those creators riggy actually sums it up
perfectly in one of his shorts so if you
were hoping to have a perfect duplicate
of yourself who was in sync with you on
every level definitely not possible
because our personalities are created by
the experiences we've gone through all
our lives those real world clone Tick
Tock accounts might be able to steal and
upload videos but they're never gonna be
those creators a person's work is a
culmination of their own experiences and
insights their successes and their
failures all wrapped up into a person
with their own thoughts and feelings and
in the story I think that the Clones
realize this or at least some of them do
like Royal pairs clone during one of his
shorts he seems to have second thoughts
about all the Mindless creation of
content that's now his life all websites
on the internet are malicious or are out
to get you oh do I really have to do
this ad read yes I don't know about you
but I want to do something more I get we
exist for a single purpose and all but
isn't our mortal existing than just
making shorts and later as he's
interrogating the real Royal pair the
Clone feels bad about it dude I'm sorry
I have to tie you up my boss will kill
me if I don't he's only doing it because
his boss the algorithm that needs
content is demanding it but here's the
thing there's another path in all of
this you can take the content of a
creator that you love and do your own
past you can use it as inspiration to
create your own art even if it's similar
to the people who inspired you it'll be
uniquely yours because you're the one
who made it and here's the spoiler alert
nothing is ever wholly original anymore
I mean Mozart and da Vinci didn't create
their own Works in a vacuum they were
inspired by what they enjoyed looking at
and listening to your favorite YouTubers
exactly the same here's Johnny razer's
thoughts before they started the ARG and
I don't care if you re-upload my stuff
as long as you're giving me credit and
not trying to be me but people in the
comments seem to have lost the plot and
linked me to people making similar
content but still their own I'm not the
first guy to talk in front of a green
screen or have bad ideas heck I was
inspired to do the green screen by naked
Jakey I want to be an inspiration Let
Them Be Inspired make stuff just do it
couldn't have said it better myself
Johnny I was pretty darn inspired by all
of your Collective work onward to season
two my friends but hey that's just a
theory a film Theory and cut